[Music]
[Music]
good evening I'm Alexander Rose I'm the
executive director here at the long now
foundation actually I wanted to find out
how many people in the audience are
members Wow all right hands down how
many of you are guests of members thanks
yeah so we've been doing this series
since 2003 there's been about a hundred
and seventy plus lectures in the series
since that time through the course of
the year we get about a little over
8,000 people through the doors for talks
like this and but that the largest
outreach that we have is actually
through the media that gets produced
from the series almost a million
downloads of some kind a year and so
it's a often now used to be the clock
project in some way was something that
was the touchstone for a lot of people
but we now find that it's the lecture
series and I wanted to talk a little bit
about how that gets supported and
actually fundamentally it gets supported
by you our members and 50 percent of the
cost of this series which cost several
hundred thousand dollars a year is
supported by you so I want to thank you
all for that the other chunk is
supported by our seminar sponsors who
pay about between 15 and 40 thousand
dollars a year to keep this thing going
and as well as our seminar media sponsor
which we now have an opening for the
main media sponsor and one of the things
we really want to do is actually cover a
little bit less of this with membership
because the membership money is also our
general fund that keeps the lights on
and things like that so if there is an
interest in helping us as a media
sponsor and reaching those million
people that might happen to like long
now things please do let our team know
we would really appreciate it as many of
you know we before these talks we often
do a long short or a short film about
long term thinking and there's no better
one or no better footage that I know
then to really talk about the scale and
the scaling laws that we've seen affect
our planet then seeing the Earth from
space at night enjoy
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
so that video sort of answers the
question of can cities be thought of as
organic because you're basically seeing
a civilization metabolizing and going by
very quickly there something I've
discovered over the years is that
biologists and physicists sort of glare
at each other biologists think
physicists especially theoretical
physicists are very abstract and
lifeless and the physicists think that
biology is seriously squishy and seems
to consist entirely in two special cases
so drawing any general pattern is kind
of hopeless and for a while when the
Santa Fe Institute first got going and
mentioned here that George calenders
founder of that was one of the first
funders of this series this was
basically a bunch of physicists coming
down the mountain from Los Alamos to
think about complex adaptive systems and
I said from my background it's biology
you need some biologists and they said
well that would be very nice do you
happen to know Winnie yeah and that went
on for a few years and eventually they
got some and our speaker tonight was
president of the Santa Fe Institute for
a while and they came up he came up in
some of the biologists they started
working with came up with something
quite profound and back when I was
studying biology at Stanford in the 50s
we were all reading a book by a
theoretical physicist who got a Nobel
Prize named Irvine Schrodinger
Schrodinger wrote a book called what his
life and he was going down to the
fundamental sort of entropy level of
what his life do that is actually unique
and his insights led to among other
things the discovery of the double helix
and inspired a generation of biologists
and what
Jeffrey West the speaker tonight came up
with in terms of scaling and life and
life as it goes on to include culture
cities and companies and so on I think
it's something that biologists and many
other disciplines will study the way we
just we studied shredding her please
welcome Jeffrey West
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you thank you Stuart for that
lovely introduction and thank you in
particular for inviting me back I talked
in this long now series a few years ago
and it's lovely to be back especially in
this marvelous auditorium so this title
was actually suggested I would even say
imposed upon me by Stuart and indeed I'm
going to talk about the growth and the
pace of life and I'm certainly going to
talk about universal laws and but at the
back of my mind in this and what I hope
to be able to lead us up to at the end
of the talk is the whole question of the
future of our planet and whether you
know this marvelous socioeconomic
edifice that we've constructed is
actually sustainable the whole question
of global sustainability and that's how
I want to try to finish up the talk but
that of course involves these other
things that are mentioned up here of
course the the kind of life history of
the various living things on the planet
organisms biological phenomena cities
and of course companies which are part
of socio-economic life but they're all
living beings so to speak and they're
all complex systems they all adapt and
evolve so I come to it as indicated by
Stuart as a physicist theoretical
physicist
and that means that in order to address
this what I'm trying to think of is
really asking the question is it
conceivable to have a quantitative
predictive science of cities companies
and organisms and so as I said this is
just saying what I've already said that
I'm coming to it from it as a physicist
from a physicists viewpoint but I've
spent a lot of time doing biology and
I'm going to bring that to bear on the
question of cities and companies and
sustainability and to provide the
background I first want to remind you of
stuff that you're actually familiar with
although you may have may not have
thought about it in this light and that
is everybody is familiar with the idea
that we live in a expanding universe
this is you know this marvelous idea
that coming out of the Big Bang the
universe is expanding at an exponential
rate but many of us are not so familiar
with something that's incredibly close
at home and affects our daily lives and
that is that we live in a exponential
expanding socio-economic universe and I
want to just dwell on that for a moment
and just to give you a metric of that
you know 200 years ago the United States
was just a few percent urban it was
mostly rural agricultural and today it's
well over 80% the planet crossed that
the halfway mark the planet is more than
50% urbanized that happened just a few
years ago and somewhere towards the end
of the century the planet as a whole
will move towards this 70 to 80 percent
urbanization and to put that in
perspective if you just average from now
to 2050 that's equivalent to urbanizing
that means people building
infrastructure organizing at the rate of
well over a million people well over a
million people every week actually about
1.4 million a week and
that's equivalent to adding as I've
written down they're adding a new york
metropolitan area every couple of months
from now to mid-century which is kind of
extraordinary or to bring it close to
home adding the city of San Francisco
the equivalent in terms of population
and infrastructure every four or five
days so that's what you're living in and
that's going on inextricably that's
going to be going on to mid-century so
you know the stress on resources on
energy on the social fabric is
phenomenal and we need to begin to try
to understand that another example of
that is China which was extremely slow
to urbanize but it's now crossed the
halfway mark and is building they claim
to be building and indeed they sort of
have to build of the order of two to
three hundred new cities in the next 15
to 20 years each in excess of a million
people so that's you know that's just
China and then there's India and then
there's Africa and Latin America and so
forth so it's a fantastic enterprise
that we are part of and it's going to
affect everybody so we just saw this
marvelous short which was fantastic and
that indeed is you know there's another
illustration of it this extraordinary
effect that human beings have had on the
planet a picture if we'd been able to
take a picture like this when I was a
child there were just been a few bright
lights and it's you know what has
happened in this short period of time is
this filigree this beautiful filigree
which you could also think of as a virus
has infected the planet and of course
that is that is a manifestation of this
extraordinary phenomenon that if you go
back 10,000 years for when men and women
started talking to one another and
forming communities coming out of being
hunter-gatherers and forming communities
ultimately leading to cities we've had
this extraordinary
growth of the population which went
completely bonkers beginning with the
Industrial Revolution where it just shot
straight up so I was born in 1940 and if
you look at that there were just over 2
billion people on this planet and now
there's seven and a half billion that
number is going to somewhere close to
maybe ten billion maybe even greater at
the end of the century so we're on this
extraordinary crazy ride and we need to
understand what it is and we need to
understand in particular the role of
cities in doing that so that's all
represented by this paradigm of growth
open-ended growth which has been
enormously successful the kind of
capitalist entrepreneurial system which
has led us to this
and here's another metric of what has
happened this is the GDP of the United
States since just after the Civil War
and you can see it just keeps zooming up
and all the little dips and bumps and
the crises a minor so you know you
didn't have to be a genius to make a lot
of money in principle because if you'd
invested $1 after the Civil War that
would be worth a million dollars today
even allowing for inflation and that's
just a metric of how extraordinary the
success of this societal economic
expansion has been so this is maybe the
only equation I have in this talk
everything what I'm going to be talking
about underneath it is a lot of
mathematics and technicalities which I
will show none but this is an equation
and this is that the equation that yeah
that what I've already indicated that
the fate of the planet in terms of our
socio-economic activity and the effect
it's going to have on the environment is
completely integrated with the fate of
our cities and and you know the term
Anthropocene has been used for the our
present era but I actually would prefer
to call it the Urbano scene because it's
really what's happened you know what we
have done in terms of glomer rating
these incredible edifices like this
marvelous city were in now but
the planet and beautifully exemplified
by that short that that is dominated the
planet so people started dominating the
planet well before cities came along so
that's why I like to distinguish the two
so here's what cities this is you know
what cities are they come in all kinds
of shapes or forms and sizes and as I
said a moment ago in order to come to
terms of this we you certainly need a
science of cities and we need to
understand these kinds of phenomena that
go along with it it's they're resilient
they are how they evolve how they grow
are they scalable and that leads into
sustainability in a term I like to coin
is that we somehow need a grand unified
theory of sustainability that includes
everything that's going on in this
planet and I will come back to that near
the end so we're all familiar with why
cities are so attractive there's great
there's greater material well-being in
cities typically there's greater
opportunities there's a greater sense of
buzz there's cultural events there's
events like this take place in cities
there's sexy restaurants and lots of
good education and so on and so forth
all of this is a tremendous magnet that
attracts people to cities and again I
will return to that in a moment to
elaborate on it but none of this can
happen none of this can happen without
energy energy is the most fundamental
quantity that drives this and
so and and there's the one thing that
I'm sure many of you at least somewhat
familiar with that there's a fundamental
law of physics called the second law of
thermodynamics
now the second law of thermodynamics is
actually the most fundamental law of
physics is inviolable and what it says
roughly speaking is that if you want to
create lots of order so you build a city
you build a company you built an
organism you create order by using
energy inevitably you're gonna create
disorder somewhere else and that
disorder
by the name of entropy so there's a
fundamental theorem the second law of
thermodynamics is that entropy increases
so that says that when you create order
you have unintended consequences and in
particular when you create
socio-economic systems you have
socio-economic entropy and that we
recognize in phenomena like this
and this and this and this and this and
of course this social unrest and indeed
I would speculate that a significant
part of the social unrest we see across
the globe whether it's when where it's
put in terms of ethnic cultural or
religious terms is actually driven a lot
by this extraordinary phenomena that
we're going through and the stresses and
strains that that inevitably causes and
one of the deep questions we have to ask
ourselves is this what cities and in
particular maybe even San Francisco are
going to look like in 50 or a hundred
years or something like this so this is
the kind of question I want to we want
to think about so when you think of
cities you usually think you know your
image is usually physical so you think
of you know the boulevards of Paris and
the Eiffel Tower you think of the
skyscrapers of New York and so on and so
forth but of course that's when you
actually think about what a city is
that's actually just the stage that's
just the platform upon which all our
lives and all the social networks and
all the information and all the
creativity is taking place and in fact
you could think of the city as maybe one
of our greatest inventions because it
because it is the place that facilitates
social interaction such as gathering
like this but in particular on a ongoing
daily basis social interaction that
creates wealth that creates ideas and
stimulates innovation
so this is much more what a city looks
like it's the interaction of the
physicality with the social or this
people sitting around bullshitting in
Paris this is a crucial aspect of cities
or this which is wrong and this is a
marvelous picture because you see that
the stage has been there for two
thousand years it's the same stage
different people but facilitating a
place of interaction people to come
together interact and I found this
picture this is your city this is San
Francisco of bringing people together or
this my city London when I was a boy
that's what it looked like and this for
some of you may be from New York that's
what New York they used to look like 120
years ago and it's a fantastic picture
because you can this really viscerally
feel the interaction you can feel the
entrepreneurship the the ideas the the
whole creativity that's going on and the
yearning for something more for a good
life and so forth and of course New York
doesn't look like this anymore that is
the people aren't there anymore doing
this but the buildings are exactly the
same it's just like that picture of Rome
but what is happening in New York the
spirit of what's going on there is still
happening in New York and it's still
happening and it's happening in San
Francisco but it's happening inside
buildings in a different venue but
provided by the infrastructure so a
crucial aspect of dealing with this
city's kinds of systems is the
interaction between the physicality of
the system Stewart used the word
metabolism the metabolism of an organism
and tribalism of a city the physical
part of it the way energy is being used
to sustain life whatever it is but and
that going through the infrastructure
the tension between that and information
exchange which is what we discovered
beginning about 10,000 years ago
language to exchange information and
therefore as I've already elaborated on
create ideas and wealth so all of the
problems that we face as we move ahead
all the big issues that we face from
climate change global warming from
questions of is there enough energy
available are there enough resources
there's enough water to questions of
health to questions of pollution and so
forth all of these have their origins in
cities that's because that's where the
people are cities generate all of the
problems that we have to face and the
problems have become much more apparent
in the last 20 years only because we've
been expanding exponentially they've
grown huge in the last 20 years not
because they weren't there before
they've always been there
they have just now started to become a
kind of tsunami so cities on the one
hand are the problem in the sense that's
where the action takes place that leads
to these issues but they're also the
solution because as I've already
indicated because they're the vacuum
cleaners that suck up people that
attract people that's where all the
ideas are created that's all the wealth
is created the other aspect of cities is
that everything goes on there so here's
just a laundry an arbitrary laundry list
that's not complete of all the various
aspects of a city and the important
thing to recognize about this is that
each one of these is a highly complex
system that itself is evolving but more
importantly all of these systems are
taking place and interacting together
they're not to be thought of as separate
and one of the problems that we face in
dealing with our issues such as global
warming or energy or health is that we
tend to stovepipe them and one of the
things that we learn when we studying
complex systems especially evolving
adaptive systems is that it is dangerous
and often misleading to think of them as
independent these different pieces is
independent and not to see them
holistically and in
rated and interacting with each other
and that's what I said there so now I'm
going to switch gears a little bit and
talking about biology and I'm doing this
for lots of reasons one is it gives us a
template and a way of thinking that we
can come back to and talk about cities
and sustainability but the other reason
is that it brings up some interesting
questions of themselves and in
particular if we ask about can we have a
science of cities and sustainability for
instance the answer is not in the way I
said quantitative predictive like
physics is meaning that we can make
predictions to arbitrary accuracy that's
why you know you can your cell phone
works after all because we send signals
up to satellites and they come back and
we know exactly where that satellite is
we know exactly how to control the
position of the satellite how to control
those signals and so forth that's
because those systems are what we call
simple as distinct from complex and we
understand the fundamental equations
that describe them but when we come to
something like a city or an organism
that's going to be impossible there's
just too many components too many actors
on the stage at the same time and one
would need maybe an infinite number of
equations so it's impossible so does
that mean that we can't do anything the
answer is no because there's maybe
something in between and that's what we
call a coarse-grained description
meaning something that's low resolution
and I want to illustrate that by example
and that's the following question so
well maybe our for doing an I'm gonna
make a prediction the prediction is
everybody in this room will be dead in a
hundred years and you can ask yourself
the question why is that why can't some
of us live for a thousand years or even
a million years where in the hell does a
hundred years come from why should be a
hundred years
that is a coarse-grain question and the
answer to it would be a coarse-grained
explanation meaning that we ought to be
understand the order of magnitude the
scale of human life without necessarily
being able to predict how long your
brand is going to live for example
so that's coarse-grained and so here it
is so why do we live a hundred years and
not a thousand or two to three years
like a mouse and let me tell you a mouse
is tissue a mouse is made of the same
stuff as we are pretty much the same
thing and yet somehow that dies after
two to three years whereas we can live
up to a hundred years so there's the
questions where do these things come
from or for example a similar question
why is it that everybody is going to go
home tonight and sleep for somewhere of
the order of eight hours why eight why
isn't it 16 or 17 hours like a mouse
this little mouse has to sleep sixteen
or seventy or you know I'm gonna stop so
I can see how many people in this room
know how long an elephant sleeps don't
say it
he dies an elephant sleeps of the about
four hours a night and the whale about
two now why is that where does that come
from so that's the those are
coarse-grain questions and I'm not in
this talk and I answer them but if you
read my book if you read my book you can
find the answer so another set of
coarse-grained questions are you know
our citizen comfort it's just very large
organisms they after all they evolved
from biology through us are they like
organisms we often use metaphors like
you know the DNA of the company the
metabolism of the city the ecology of
the marketplace and all those other sort
of [ __ ] metaphors that people write
best-selling books about and the
question is is there any serious
substance to that and the corollary to
that and in fact what got me into
this this some of these things I'm going
to talk about is this intriguing
question why is it that we die
that's the previous question but all
companies die its companies eventually
die like we do or they disappear but
cities don't I mean you can always think
of examples of classic examples of Mayan
cities or ancient Greek cities that have
died but one cities it's almost
impossible to kill them
we dropped at embalms on two cities
seventy eighty years ago whenever that
was and those cities 20 30 years later a
fine but a small fluctuation in the
stock market or the externalities and
you lose a TWA
you lose a Montgomery Ward's you're
going to lose Sears we should have lost
General Motors we lost Lehman Brothers
so companies are extremely fragile but
cities are extraordinary resilient and I
will come back to that so that's one of
the things to be discussed or this what
the hell happens
that's too close to home okay so here's
a his three mammals we're one of these
mammals span we span we span a range of
eight orders of magnitude one hundred
million in our size from the Shrew which
consists of this big to the blue whale
which is much bigger than this
auditorium and they look different they
have different evolutionary histories
but in fact as I'm now going to show you
we're actually scaled versions of one
another to a remarkable degree sort of
eighteen ninety percent degree it's
concerning anything that you can measure
about them
any physiological characteristic about
them and I'm going to show you some or
any life history event life history
event meaning how long did they take to
mature what was their growth rate how
long do they live how fast as oxygen
diffuse across some membrane inside them
they're all scaled versions one another
and here's the most fundamental example
it's your metabolic rate roughly
speaking how much energy did you do you
need to stay alive
how much food you need to eat to stay
alive and it's plotted on the vertical
axis that's metabolic rate and on the
horizontal axis is the size of the
animal the mass the weight of the animal
and is plotted you see by factors of ten
one ten a hundred a thousand and and so
forth so that you get a mouse and
elephant on the same graph because if
you put the mouse here and you try to
put an elephant on a linear graph one
two three four five six seven eight all
the way up to the size of an elephant it
would be I don't know where it would be
Abby South San Francisco or somewhere
it'd be a long way away so you we plot
it this way and it's called logarithmic
this is called just logarithmic and the
what is amazing about this is that
something extraordinary simple emerges
whereas we're dealing with something
that's maybe the most complex phenomenon
in the you
metabolism how you take stuff and you
make life out of it that's what we do
when we eat and furthermore each one of
these organisms each subsystem each
organ each cell type each gene gene type
of it has its own unique history each
one has evolved with its own unique
historical contingencies in its own
specific set of environments in which
case you would have thought you have
this sense of sort of certain randomness
associated with natural selection that
when you plot it something like this the
points would be spread all over the
graph each point simply reflecting the
evolutionary history of that particular
animal quite to the contrary they've
lined up beautifully along this straight
line ISM of these fluctuations around it
but it's beautifully beautiful fit to
this furthermore the slope of that line
as I've written there is very close to
this curious number of 3/4 now if the
number had been one one would have sort
of understood in a very trivial way one
would have said well ok you double the
size of an organism you double the
number of cells therefore you need twice
as much energy that's called linear
quite to the contrary you double the
size of an organism whatever it is then
instead of needing twice as much energy
to keep it alive
you only need 75% there's a 25% saving
roughly speaking every time you double
and that's what that graph says so
there's that's quite an economy of scale
and the fact that you have that economy
of scale and that number 3/4 is less
than 1 is called sub linear so these two
things are actually scaled versions of
one another
amazingly so that's what I've summarized
here and this is true as I mentioned a
moment ago of any physiological variable
that you can measure and I just show you
one or two here
here is heart rate something quite
mundane written the number of times your
heart beats a minute and what you see
again it's a very nice regular
systematic scaling and the slope of this
as I've indicated there is very close to
1/4 it says - 1/4 - meaning only that
it's going downwards instead of upwards
here's you or what you think of as you
this is your brain this is your white
matter - gray matter in the brain you
remember the the white matter is sort of
the cables and the gray matter is the
processing part and it's extraordinary
across this huge number of animals you
get this amazing regularity and here's
something which is has much more
fluctuations in it but nevertheless you
see similar scaling and that's genome
length of various bacteria and various
cells and so forth and you can see again
then so so I could show you I could
spend the rest of the evening boring you
with seventy five or hundred of these
kinds of things of measurements and they
all have exactly the same characteristic
when you plot them this way they all
look like straight lines and importantly
the slope of those lines is some simple
multiple of 1/4 so the number that is
somehow controlling pervading all of
life is the number for amazing number
four that's the magic number it's
amazing
with all the the you know the historical
interest in numbers you know like 3 + 7
+ 21 13 turns out four is the number so
here it is again I I should have changed
this slide but I kept it because it has
some historical and romantic memories
and for me personally which is
irrelevant to this talk but what that
says there you see that second line
heart rate and that minus 1/4 that was
just that graph I just showed you this
thing decreases 1/4 that
that first thing up there T is lifespan
how long you live that increases
approximately with a slope of plus 1/4
so you've got heart rate decreasing with
a certain slope lifespan increasing and
if you multiply them together the plus
1/4 cancels the minus 1/4 so what it
says this is the only rithmetic I'm
doing all evening lifespan times heart
rate doesn't change with size it's the
same for everybody but what is lifespan
times heart rate that's the number of
heartbeats
in a lifetime so that's the same for
everybody every mammal at least so that
says that the Shrew which lives for
about a year or so and his heart beats
at some extraordinary rate over a
thousand times a minute
has the same number of heart beats in
its life as the whale which lives for
150 years and whose heart beats
boom-boom-boom that goes the same number
that is fantastic and here's the data
they are that's number they're all the
same oh we're all the same
ok well ok let me skip the next one so
so there's these curious scaling laws
and the question is whether how do they
come from why what is going on here so
the idea is and that's what this word is
up here networks is that and this is the
work I got involved in that Stewart
referred to when I was part of the
Senate when I joined the Santa Fe
Institute and that is if you ask
yourself how do organisms or any complex
system how is it sustained it has huge
numbers of components enormous numbers
of cells for example and each one has to
be serviced democratically and
efficiently and we what has happened is
that natural selection has evolved
networks to do that so we are a bunch of
networks where certain systems and renal
systems and respiratory systems and
bones and neural systems and so on and
here's just a few pictures of them there
we are that's you down at the bottom
that's the insides of you but that's
also you on the left that's your brain
white matter the gray matter the one on
the bottom right is also you it's your
networks within cells and the top one is
networks within mitochondria you're a
bunch of networks and the idea is these
networks no matter what the design is
whether it's a tree or a human being or
a mouse or a fish or a bird these
networks may have different evolved
designs but the underlying principles
the underlying physics and mathematics
of these networks are the same and it
turns out when you take that when you
take these principles and the principles
are to do with things like every cell
has to be fed by the network but you
take these ideas and you put them into
mathematics all of these scaling laws
come tumbling out and the origin of the
one quarter the number four also gets
revealed and I'm going to come back to
that near at the very end as to what
that number four represents but the
point is there is now a complete theory
for understanding not just the origin
and scaling laws but the way all your
networks work so how your circuitry
system works your respiratory system
work and so on and I'm not going to
dwell on that because I want to get on
to other stuff
the last thing though I am gonna do in
this context is to talk about growth as
one example and when you have a theory
you can now apply it to many things
growth is one and growth of course is a
scaling phenomenon you scaled as you
grew and you know how you did that in a
certain sense you ate that's on the left
there you ate you metabolize the energy
and that energy goes through the network
to feed cells and when it reaches those
cells it and that's what I've written
down here it maintains those that are
there it repairs damage it ones that
have died replaces and then it
new ones so you can put this into
mathematics this is just symbolic up
there and when you do it you can derive
how organisms should grow what is the
growth curve so to speak of an organism
and here's an example this is us such as
a rat and what you see there is the
weight versus age and the line the solid
line there is from this theory based on
this equation which is written in
English here but if you write it in
mathematics gives rise to that and those
points there are data points and you say
it's very good and you can do this for
any organism and the thing that is
fantastic about it it's not just that it
gives it gives agreement with prediction
or good I'm sorry it gives agreement
with the data but that it's true for any
organism with the same parameters there
are just two or three Universal
parameters like the mass of the cell and
so forth they go into it which means the
following which means the theory tells
you how to rescale everybody so to speak
so that we all look as if we're growing
in the same way and that's this curve
I'm not going to explain this in detail
just to give you the idea you can see
there's just a a spectrum of animals on
this we could had many more and if you
rescale both their weight and time in a
way determined by the theory governed by
the network dynamics everybody grows in
the same way in this kind of universal
way so it's it's it's very or spiritual
to see the interconnectivity with all of
them and indeed there's something even
more bizarre it's that you can put
tumors on this and tumors because it's
us it's the same stuff and it also obeys
this so one can do many other things
with this and all the questions I asked
before about aging and mortality and
about sleep one can address within this
framework I'm not going to do that
because I want to move on to cities but
I just want to summarize what I said
that is extraordinary we have this
extraordinary complex system yet somehow
hidden in there are these extraordinary
systemic relationships these scaling
laws they're nonlinear they're dominated
by this number four they express an
economy of scale the bigger you are the
less you need per capita I didn't
emphasize that the bigger you are the
let your cells of a bigger animal work
less hard than a smaller animal I also
didn't emphasize that the pace of life
systematically slows as an animal gets
bigger I said that about heart rates
oxygen diffusion across membranes and so
forth all of these slow down so that
just to go back to the image of the
elephant we know how to rescale
everything about an elephant
so that including its life span so that
when you scale it down it's a mouse or
us or one or us even growth stops that's
a very important point and I want to
just go back to that for one moment for
this that one of the features of this
that the theory explains is why it is
that you grow at the beginning you keep
eating and yet you stop growing and that
is intimately related to this sub linear
behavior this this idea that the bigger
you are the less you need per capita
that feeds into this by ending up
stopping growth so that we have this
interesting relationship between the
scaling of metabolic rate being sub
linear economies of scale and leading to
the cessation of growth and finally that
these systems will die they died because
the wear and tear
due to metabolism eventually leads to
their demise and then gives rise to
those scaling laws for lifespan I'm just
telling you done explaining it and you
just have to take my word for it and all
of this comes that last point there is
explained by the dynamics
these and the structure of these
networks and these universal properties
of those networks okay
so now I'm going to take this framework
and apply it to cities so I said before
in my introduction that we urgently need
to ask at least the question is there a
science of cities that is in some way
predictable and quantitative so the
first question taking this paradigm is
to ask our cities scaled versions one
another because before what we showed is
that the whale is actually to all
intents and purposes amazingly a scaled
up giraffe which is a scaled up human
being which is a scaled up Mouse in
terms of these physiological and
life-history
metrics so is it is it so that New York
is a scaled up Los Angeles which is a
scaled up San Francisco which is a
scaled up Santa Fe even though they look
different they have different histories
geographies and cultures but that was
true of those animals they have
different histories and so on and and is
there anything Universal about them well
at first of course you might think well
they look completely different
nevertheless of course conceptually they
do our network structures cities our
network structures in terms of their
physicality they have transport systems
and they have electrical lines and
plumbing lines and and gas lines and so
on they have these transport systems and
they're supplied by networks but I
already emphasized earlier that's the
physical part of a city but maybe the
more important part of a city because
that's the whole point of cities is
placed for people and I couldn't resist
putting this in Shakespeare of course
who knew everything and understood
everything and understood that cities
are people and indeed this is a
representation of that we are social
networks each node in that is a person
and those lines there are just the
connections between them so this is some
this is the one's image one's abstract
image of social interaction between
people this is a classic image but
there's something very special about
these network
because there are two points that are
often not emphasized and often forgotten
when we analyze these kinds of things
first is these networks have a modular
property meaning that that's illustrated
here that we're all members of groups in
some way the most fundamental being
family but we have jobs and we have
groups in the job we have departments
and so on and there's a kind of
hierarchy of group structure modular
structure which is constraining this
network whatever it is the second point
is and that's well as illustrated here
that even though when we think of
networks especially in the modern lingo
of you know Facebook and all the rest of
that stuff that we think of it somehow
out there in the cloud up there in the
cyberspace but of course you know
there's there's some truth of that
because there has to be transmitted by
electromagnetic waves but the real the
reality is when you are part of a
network you have to be somewhere you
you're in someplace you're sitting in
your living room you're sitting on the
toilet you're waiting for the bus you're
in your office you have to be somewhere
when you're using your cell phone or
you're using your computer and so forth
so these networks also have a huge
constraint that they have to be wedded
in some way to the two-dimensional
surface upon which we live so let's move
on from there and ask the question are
cities in fact scale versions one
another and here's something mundane
again this is number of gas stations
it's called petrol stations in the
picture because I did this work with
some my German colleagues in Switzerland
and you can see there's very good
evidence of scaling they there's a
regular behavior there and that dotted
line would be linear so this is like
biology the slope is less than 1 its sub
linear which means there's an economy of
scale meaning the bigger the city
the less the number of gas stations you
need per capita well that's not so
surprising what is surprising it's the
same savings roughly speaking whatever
country you're in at least as far as
these four a concern because the slopes
of these are roughly speaking the same
the slopes of these are roughly 0.85
rather than 0.75 that we saw in biology
but what is amazing is that if you look
across the globe
you see the same result so you see the
same thing for gas stations in China
Japan Colombia Chile the United States
and so forth but even more amazing is
that if you look at any infrastructure
any infrastructure across the globe
meaning the length of all the roads the
length of all the electoral lines
whatever whatever it is that's
infrastructure physical infrastructure
and you plot it this way they look
exactly like this they have the same
slope 0.85 the same 15% savings so put
into English it says every time you
double the size of a city you don't need
twice as many gas stations or twice the
length of the roads
you only need 85% as much so you get
this marvelous saving of economies of
scale that means by the way that in
terms of transport and pollution caused
by transport since you're saving the
bigger you are you have less pollution
per capita the bigger the city which
means the carbon footprint is smaller
the bigger the city which means that New
York City is in fact the greenest city
in the United States which it is you're
not as green doesn't matter you know I
don't care how whatever you do in terms
of your recycling and all the rest
you're not as green as New York and the
most profligate is Santa Fe where I live
because it's so small it's inefficient
ok so big cities are good in that way
but that's that's kind of this is the
biological side the infrastructural
policy is the more interesting
sneaking part of a city is what
therefore people and socio-economic
metrics and these are two of them to
begin with
that's wages at the top and the bottom
is something called super creators which
is like everybody in this room
kind of sexy professional buzzy
that's super creators and what you see
here is there's again there's more
there's some noise in the system so to
speak there's variance but you see good
evidence of scaling but the slope of
these Arthur for the first time bigger
than one rather than smaller than one
this is called super linear scaling and
both of these slopes are very close to
1.15 that's that beta up there which
means the bigger the city not less per
capita the bigger the city more per
capita higher wages per capita more sexy
people per capita more patents per
capita more innovation per capita to the
same degree I forgot to put the number
on this more crime per capita more
police per capita more taxes per capita
more fancy restaurants per capita all to
the same degree always always the same
this 15 percent value added so to speak
the bigger you are no matter where you
are in the world and just there's a
little panel four of them you can see
some I already show but down there's the
GDP of France there's those restaurants
but they all you can just see by eye
there will have pretty much the same
slope and there's a kind of universality
and that's represented here just this is
just the United States this is income
GDP crime and patterns and they've been
adjusted to lie on top of one another
but you can see they have the same slope
there's again lots of variance and to
put all of that into English it's that
the good the bad and ugly all come
together in terms of socio economic
activity if you double the size of a
city in any given urban system then
income wealth patterns educational
institutions creative people police
ADEs flu cases crime whatever all of
them increase to the same degree by
approximately 15% independent of the
city and you save approximately 15% on
all infrastructure and since we're very
good at repressing the negative the fact
that there's more crime more disease in
a bigger city biggest cities in general
are better in terms of many of these
metrics and the bigger the city the
better it is both individually there's
greater opportunity there's greater bars
all the things I said earlier but
there's a collective savings of this 15
percent on infrastructure and this is no
doubt one of the fundamental reasons why
cities continued it to be attractive and
why we have this phenomenon of mega
cities so again we ask the question how
can it be the cities in Japan and cities
in the United States and cities in
Portugal for example or scale in the
same way these urban systems all scale
in the same way it's not as if there was
a congress and you know 1810 that
everybody got together and said this is
how we're going to design urban systems
it's how we're going to design cities so
they conform to these rules just as in
biology this evolved organically by the
interaction of human beings and that
leads one to the idea that underlying
this is the universality in terms of the
mathematics and the physics of social
interactions social networks and that
the reason that it's the same all over
the globe is that the nature of these
networks our social interactions are in
this course train sense the same that
the structure for example the modularity
sizes of families the size of the groups
that we interact with are pretty much
the same across the globe and so so one
can develop a theory just as one did for
the biology and I'm not going
- I'm not going to show you the
mathematics but you know one of the one
of the marvelous things about science is
not just that one analyzes things that
one courage theories and models that
where we can understand the phenomena
but one of its great triumphs is that we
predict things that haven't been
measured or we make predictions about
other things that can be tested and then
we have this kind of positive feedback
mechanism of scientific the scientific
method so I just want to illustrate that
with this so when you look at this
universality and you say well what I
just said that underlying it is actually
the social dynamics inherent in social
networks that means they are a measure
of somehow the degree of interaction as
a function of city size so that means
that if we could measure independently
how often people interact in cities and
plotted versus the function of city size
it should just look like wanted this
fall on top of that so how do you do
that well it was very difficult until
recently but now everybody and everybody
in this room carries with them a little
detector right you all carry a cell
phone of some kind and as you well know
every time you make a call the telephone
company records it they know every call
you made they know where you are they
know how long that core took place they
know to whom you called it and they keep
records of that and I have some
colleagues at MIT that were able to get
hold of all those records and I've I
mean not individually of course but it's
scrubbed but we have those records
billions and billions of phone calls so
here's what you do with that you say I
called Stewart and then within six
months just to take some arbitrary time
you call me back
we define that as a relationship that's
a social interaction not just you
calling me but there's a reciprocating
so we count those as a in every city and
then we add them all up and we plot that
and the prediction is that it should
look just like that so here it is there
it is
and what that is the two different
colors represent two different countries
Portugal and the United Kingdom
and you can see they lie on top of one
another as they should and they are
parallel to the other one with the same
slope that the indeed confirming or at
least strongly indicating then indeed
underlying this extraordinary scaling of
quantities that seem to have no
relationship to each other is in fact
the dynamic of social networks and
social interactions okay now I have been
going on already too long I suspect so
I'm going to miss there all this
fantastically interesting stuff I'm
gonna miss out so I do want to do this
so under two other major things one is
networks underlie all of this as I've
indicated and one of the properties of
these networks by the way which I
probably should have emphasized is that
they are fractal like they have this
that is they have a self-similar
property to them they look this very
similar at different scales and those
come out of these principles of networks
some of which are optimization
principles so for example I give one
here now our circulatory system which I
mentioned earlier it has evolved by the
continuous feedback mechanisms inherent
in natural selection to be optimal in
terms of the amount of energy your heart
has to do to pump blood through the
system so just to give you an example if
you were to take the tenth branch of
your circuitry system and increase it by
15% your heart would have to work harder
if you decreased it by 15% it would have
to work hard
you decrease it by anything or increase
to by anything you would have to work
harder and that's true for every part of
your network so you're in this deep
basin of optimization it's fantastic and
that gives rise to these scaling laws it
turns out and the idea behind that is
that you've optimized the amount of
energy you need to stay alive in order
to maximize the allocation you can do
give believe it or not to sex and
reproduction Darwinian fitness or you
can for your progeny so one of the
outcomes of that of that network
dynamics that I've already mentioned is
that if we have sub linear behavior as
we do in biology the 3/4 power law then
the pace of life slows down it turns out
the kinds of networks that social
networks even though the mathematics is
similar it has a different dynamic and
that is a positive feedback loop in
which case I talked to Stewart he talks
to Alex you talk to me and then we start
conversing and we build up we have this
extraordinary phenomenon once we
discovered language of building on each
other's ideas building on each other's
interactions and so forth and that has
led to all of this which is
extraordinary so so even though the
networks look similar and they have
similar properties this one crucial
property that we have invented namely
this positive feedback loop of enhancing
interactions and therefore leading to
wealth creation and ideas and innovation
also leads to an opposite behavior in
terms of the pace of life and I've
indicated up there the pace of life
speeds up it's sort of slowing down that
phenomenon speeds up the pace of life in
a predictable way and I will illustrate
that in the following on the right on
the left is some other data on heart
rates and you see the decrease on the
right is the increase and that's the
pace of walking in city
and the prediction of the theory is that
redline and you can see there you know
it said there's some variance of course
in it but it's sort of amazing and
because it is true when you walk in a
city you are still part of the network
and here's an interesting phenomenon
that has come about because of that look
at this this is a picture that was in a
British newspaper about six months ago
in the city of Liverpool and the caption
is been rewritten here so you can read
it this is amazing research revealed
almost half the nation found the slow
pace of high streets to be their biggest
shopping bugbear not the noise and the
pollution and nor the other you know
things that keep people away from cities
it's just that people are walking too
slow so what did Liverpool do they
introduced and that's what this picture
is a fast lane for walking and other
cities are beginning to follow it it's
so there you are the pace of life is
inextricably increasing because of this
super linear behavior and here's another
one this one's dear to my heart because
it drives me absolutely explosive mad
where you're from it so I want to now
just do I will finish up with this I'm
not going to talk about companies I'm
gonna finish up with this I think growth
so you remember what I did for organisms
it was basically this equation I've
written in English it's not written in
mathematics but you had metabolism you
had metabolic rate or food you
metabolize you then have metabolic
energy you allocate some of it to
repairing cells and when you grow you
add new cells and that gave rise to this
this graph this picture and we're a very
good agreement with data and and we
understood bounded growth and I told you
bounded growth
is intimately related to this sublinear
economy of scale behavior so here the
equation so to speak is a little more
complicated because many things go into
running city keeping a city viable and
and so forth but it's the same
conceptual framework the whatever is
coming in whether it's you know
literally energy or resources or ideas
or products or whatever these all have
to be lumped together that goes towards
maintenance and what's already there you
repair the roads and the building's
you've repaired the people you get their
doctors and hospitals but there's repair
maintenance and then there's growth you
grow all the construction that you see
in San Francisco that's part of the
growth and you grow new people of course
you produce new people so you can write
this down in mathematics and the
equation and as I say if it was sub
linear we would have this which we would
consider terrible in our paradigm in our
present socio-economic paradigm that
things stopped things are not supposed
to stop we have you're supposed to have
open-ended growth and indeed what is
very satisfying is that with super
linear scaling you get open-ended growth
and I've just made a cartoon of it here
and that's wonderful and I could show
you lots of data that this agrees with
but I just want to show you a cartoon
version on it and that's marvelous
except for one fatal flaw and the fatal
flaw is that dotted line as you see on
the left the straight line vertical line
is something that's nothing to do with
this slide I think that's to do with the
projection but it's the dotted line is
what you have to look at and that dotted
line is called in the mathematical Lego
a finite time singularity and what does
this mean in English this means that in
some finite time in the future 10 years
20 years 100 years the whatever you're
plotting here could be
number of AIDS cases it could be wages
it could be the GDP that is going to
infinity which is obviously nuts
that can't happen and indeed the theory
tells you what happens and that's given
on the right the the system stagnates
and then it collapses that's the end of
it so how do you avoid that well we know
how we avoid that and we know how we
have avoided it and I will finish off
with this part that is that you
recognize I've redrawn it there it is
you go up and you would hit this finite
time singularity and the system would be
in trouble but you recognize that this
growth has taken place within a given
paradigm and that paradigm is determined
by some major innovation usually like we
and we discovered bronze of some stage
or we discovered calls that the
Industrial Revolution going or we
invented computers and more recently IT
each one of these represents a major
paradigm shift or a some major change
which effectively resets the clock so
the idea is as you go along this growth
you have to before you hit this
transition this potential transition
which is going to take you over the
cliff you better do something major make
a shift of paradigm so that you can
start growing again and that's what that
is and of course what would happen is
you take another finite time singularity
soon enough so you better do it again
and again and again and somehow didn't
compile properly with those dots like
apologize but you have this idea of
continuous innovation and in fact
there's a kind of theorem if you want to
have open-ended growth you want to
maintain it you have to have continuous
systematic innovation and paradigm
shifts and you have to do that in a
regular way well people have talked
about that many times but there's a
catch in this and here's the catch going
along anyway
these curves life gets faster the speed
of life gets faster going along with
that is that the time between these
innovations has to get shorter and
shorter so something that might have
taken I just sort of make this up a
hundred years a thousand years ago to
change now only takes 15 years or 20
years so the clock that we live by is
speeding up and so we have to have
another innovation you know the time
between computers laptops and IT was
maybe 20 years or so 25 years we're
going to have to have another major
innovation equivalent IT in the next
this is what this suggests in the next
20 to 25 years in fact all the data
suggests that so you can take this
argument to an absurd stage and say well
eventually you're going to have to make
a major innovation like that every two
years and then every one year and then
every six months and so the system will
collapse ultimately anyway so any major
innovation is just postponing just
putting things off so that's the idea
and so we have to come to terms with
that here's this is not my stuff this is
someone plotted here how long it took to
reach Ted this is just a way of
representing that 10 million customers
and you can see that they get shorter
and shorter with these new inventions as
we moved along in time or Ray Kurzweil
has written a book about singularity has
a completely different image of
singularities but nevertheless he put
some interesting data to get interesting
graphs and this is what this is and
what's plotted here is on the vertical
axis how long it takes to make a shift
so or let's look at the horizontal axis
a billion years ago 10 to the 9th years
ago cells were evolved and it took about
a billion years for them to evolve and
so that's what's plotted here how long
it takes to them evolve and how long ago
it did
so that the most recent whoops
the most recent you know took place just
15 years ago and took just a few years
to develop so and by the way the theory
predicts that red line that's what the
red line comes out of the whole theory
of that I've just been describing to you
so I finished there I didn't get to talk
about I talked too long already I didn't
get to talk about companies I just
wanted to leave you with one thing I'm
not gonna show you any of this this is
all fantastic stuff marvelous stuff
which you would love to have heard I'm
gonna finish with this what I didn't
point out when I showed you that graph
of metabolic rate some of you may have
looked across and see there was man and
woman on it and you looked across and it
said 90 watts so each person in this
audience waiting desperately for me to
finish this bloody thing is operating at
90 watts a light bulb that's all you
need to stay alive is the light bulb
which is fantastic we are unbelievably
efficient but we are extraordinarily
inefficient and profligate as social
human beings because in order to stay
alive with the quality and standard of
living that we have evolved so that you
need these lights you need this room you
need your car you need the eating you
need the roads you need your iPhone if
you add all that together for the social
metabolic rate that's not just a little
less than a hundred watts
it's eleven thousand watts it's a
hundred times bigger and it's equivalent
to each person in this room is
equivalent to about a dozen elephants or
about three-quarters of a blue whale and
there are seven and a half billion of us
on this planet or one thing to be like
us in one form or another and there's
another five possibly well three to five
billion coming on board so this is the
problem that we have and this is
problem we have to face and I'm not
going to I'm not going to talk about any
solutions maybe Stuart and I can as we
finish and what I'm gonna do is
shamelessly promote my book thank you
[Applause]
so Jeff the the scaling law stuff is
profound and across a whole lot of
disciplines I'm curious who is lighted
up as you and Betancourt and browning
the recipe sir brought this stuff to
light who said oh my gosh we can really
put that to work that's really important
for us who said that yeah who is excited
by hole scaling laws well that's hard
for me to say every really I mean I mean
we would imagine urban planners would be
yeah oh I see it turns out you mean in
terms of the the urban stuff the city
staff it wasn't anything about the
scaling because it is sort of trends a
whole lot of things upside down or
sideways yeah and people are
differentially realizing how important
it can be to them and I'm just curious
who gets it well in certainly among the
you know one of the things that's been
interesting is that there's been a lot
of very positive response in the among
urban planners architects who deal with
cities among well this is a big quit so
one of the big challenges in this which
I find very difficult because they're
not gonna get out of that straight line
so here's this exactly so here's the
thing that you know the leap so I I come
to it as a scientist so it's slightly
ivory tower ish I'm interested in
understanding it and having a
theoretical framework that we can
understand what the kind of big picture
they come is engineer they deal with
real problems you know you have the
sewer system and you have
your buildings and so on and you have
developments and so forth
so bridging that gap is extremely
difficult and I've spent quite a lot of
time talk trying talking to mayor's what
mayor's have been talking to me anyway
about such things and I talk at many
symposia and events both in the business
and corporate community and in the
developer community and part of the
reason I participate in that is because
I feel it's very important to somehow
not just get the ideas across but to see
how can it be actually useful and I
think one one thing to begin with is
first just having a complimentary vision
of what a city is to see it systemically
holistically that it isn't just this
piece and this piece and it isn't just
the buildings and this road and how do
you get transport from here to there
but you've got to think of it much more
holistically and urban planning has had
a very checkered history in terms of you
know you start to develop one little
area and you discover that you know it's
had some big effect over here and the
most classic examples of that are you
know cities design de novo means it is
that you know it's jr. China's building
and China is having these terrible
troubles in their solar cities so to
speak but you know Brasilia was a
disaster Washington DC because a it's
not a very interesting City or transit
city for a very long time but that's
been very typical Canberra in Australia
all of these that were design have been
not successful because cities are
organic they do grow and they are they
are like organisms in that sense and so
going back to your question it's that
you know I think that if you are a
designer if you're a planner then
you should be cognizant of this there
are these constraints that were you know
in other words you should you should
know that if you're a city so what are
these scaling laws say they say you tell
me the size of a city in the United
States mm-hmm then I can tell you with
you know 10-15 percent accuracy how many
police there should be how many AIDS
cases you should be having how many
patents should be producing what are the
average wages how much crime there
should be and so on
now there's fluctuations around that and
one of the things I flip through on that
was exactly this question what cities
and how US it is over an underperforming
relative to this baseline so this
provides a one-one of a better phrase a
kind of scientific baseline for how a
city should be given its size because
that just those metrics just come from
the fact that we are human beings and we
are part of networks and those networks
have generic properties that we have
evolved with the other audience for this
must be corporate leaders who are saying
okay Jeff West says the cities live
forever and all companies die but I
don't want my company to die so come and
tell us how to make my company more like
a city and how does that work out can I
take my will to get to you before is how
are companies different than cities yes
so let me just say a few words about
that first of all if you look at what we
did I didn't show any of this stuff but
we we got data on all 30,000 US publicly
traded companies since 1950 so all of
them and so we know now a great deal
about that dynamic and one of the things
you learn very quickly is that the
half-life meaning if you take a cohort
half of them have disappeared in ten
years so put it slightly different the
average lifespan of a US popularly
traded company when it posts on the
socket
so it's already been successful to some
extent it's about ten years so these are
like the rat they're just sublinear and
they poop out they do and in fact what I
didn't show you was the fact that the
scaling of companies in terms of the
metrics that you measure are sublinear
like us which means if you take just
what you said if you take that argument
two things follow one is that they stop
growing and they're gonna die and what I
flashed through there was to show that
companies all these 30,000 companies
start out zooming like we did and then
they all stop they all stop growing
relative by the way to the GDP that is
so that if you get in it that's why if
you get any major fluctuation companies
get into trouble because they're just
sitting on top of the so to speak the
wave and so kind of strange because the
metabolism of an animal that you know
grows quickly and then tapers off and
then dies seems significantly different
than the metabolism which s yes so
economic so the dynamic is different and
let me tell you what that dynamic is a
little bit and some of it you're very
familiar with
so the fundamental difference between a
city and a company is that a city isn't
top-down you know it doesn't have it has
a mayor your mayors and you have
administration but you know the great
city is a place that allows almost
anything to happen it encourages
entrepreneurship it it you know to make
a sort of cartoon version out of it you
know you driving here you see homeless
people you see crazy people on the
streets they provide a kind of boundary
for us you know that anything can be
thought of anything in principle can be
proposed and so forth that's quite
different that a company company is
quite rigid company is you know there
aren't even Google doesn't have you know
crazy homeless people they're all kind
of conservative MIT nerds which means
they're all you know they're all pretty
much the same there's very little
diversity whereas a city one of the
great characteristics of a city is the
extraordinary diversity in a city so I
was in New York last week and I went for
an interview somewhere and next door
there was a little shop actually wasn't
so little a shop what did it sell it's
sold only antique fireplaces now that is
extraordinary you know there's not a
shop like that probably in San Francisco
but the bigger the city the more diverse
it is and the more kind of different
kinds of activities are encouraged and
take place that's quite the opposite to
a company a company starts out maybe
having being multi-dimensional having a
large product space lots of ideas ideas
dominate but eventually the market
forces limit the product you know you
you respond of course to where your best
selves are and you have one or two or
three or four or some small number of
products and as the company grows also
you have this problem that you've got to
have a serious bureaucracy and
administration someone else to deal with
the taxes and the fact and cleaning the
offices and all the rest and so you know
innovation and ideas tend to get
squeezed out and as you well know that
when times get rough for big companies
but one of the first things they do is
limit their research and development
because they say wow this can wait for a
few years
that is the first signs of mortality
they die but some companies can do what
cities do they can try to reinvent
themselves they go try to go through
what
you know I see it to avoid a singularity
and a collapse they can reinvent
themselves and some companies have been
you know GE is a classic example it's
come from some companies have done that
but they're very few and far between
most companies tend to stay within a
certain comfort zone okay so this
suggests one of the things we're seeing
play out in the Bay Area is the sort of
suburban companies like Google and the
intensely urban companies like
Salesforce and Twitter's in town and
hugely Amazon in Seattle which is just
in what costing itself in the urban
fabric there and then some of the
companies are doing a very urban service
basically like Airbnb or uber and lyft
where you know ride hailing is it
largely an urban phenomenon and you know
I wonder if companies finding a way to
sort of blend in with the cities either
physically or in terms of their service
if that is part of the way they can
borrow some of the immortality so things
can be I could that could it could
because they they could become part of
the lifeblood of a city in a serious way
as I think from and I may I speak
without true knowledge of this but my
image of Detroit was that it wasn't true
of you know Ford and General Motors in
that sense I mean they dominate in
Detroit but they weren't the way you
just described as being you know what
you do see I agree with you an Amazon or
an uber maybe even Salesforce getting
you know coming into over the lifeblood
I don't know I don't know enough about
it but that could be a you know a way of
force tolling mortality we'll see here's
question from Saad Khan who has since
infrastructure scales sub linearly in
quality of life scale super leniently
why doesn't everyone just live in one
super awesome city
well that's like yes you know why
shouldn't there be just one big animal
you know yeah just one no the this goes
to something I didn't discuss here and
that is that you can apply this to an
ecosystem you know to a collective
forest for example and what you discover
is that of course there's two things
that happen one is you know just you
could imagine why couldn't a forest be
one great big tree instead could have
been you could have imagined that really
tall it would be really tall in fact it
wouldn't it would be so tall it would
collapse under its own weight but that's
a secondary question but it would the
reason is first of all it produces
offspring and those grow so you have
that issue but also you discover that
the optimal situation for a forest or
for a city or city an urban system is
that you have this distribution on me
you have this very regular distribution
of sizes that you need in order for the
system to optimize in terms of a
collective so I only talked you know in
this talk I kept it within you know
treating cities almost as individual and
not addressing the question of the fact
that they're all part of themselves of
an interacting system San Francisco does
not exist of itself it needs Los Angeles
Enid Chicago
it needs Sacramento it needs Eugene
Oregon I don't know it need you know all
of these are all part of the the urban
system the United States and end of the
world so when is about global said the
planet is basically a city so we're more
than half city dwellers no absolutely
and if I'm one of the most interesting
questions is to what extent is there a
real global urban system you know I mean
first of all a super system you know
New York and Singapore and Dubai and
London and so on do they form some super
urban system and because they are all
highly interdependent and so it is at
the level of you know country all the
all the cities are highly interdependent
and could not exist of themselves they
would in fact collapse under that sense
of what's under the red white on their
own economic weight you know it keeps
coming up when people talk about cities
is that they are connected I'm gonna end
with one last question which is one that
came up from your book and it's both on
the fractal realization and the number
four coming out of that but you make the
point that the living systems have this
extra dimension because their fractal so
there are three dimensional systems but
because they are fractal because our
lungs are fractal or circulatory system
our neurons are fractal and this fractal
quality adds not just three dimensions
but the capabilities the productivity
the efficiency of four dimensions and
the peculiarities so far is that living
systems have those four dimensions but
the things that we manufacture so far
don't they're just plain old 3d the
three dimensional things do you see a
prospect for manufacturing in the sense
fractal therefore four dimensional
therefore vastly more productive and
efficient devices computers for example
could that be done yeah that's a very
good question and one that I've actually
have when I first did this work the
biology part before I got into the city
work I thought a lot about that and
about that time I was contacted by some
people manufacturers who were trying to
use the idea in manufacturing okay and
in fact that led me to a an abortive
collaboration trying to do
do the following you know when in the
chemical industry I'm gonna make again a
cartoon version out of this you know
when they make stuff they put catalysts
in there to make products whatever they
are they're plastics or soap or whatever
they and they just sort of swash it all
in so to speak and what I learned from
these people was that it would be
incredibly efficient if we could do what
like we do in the body you know have a
system of the branching networks that
deliver things to specific parts of this
okay that seems weak and so we started
actually trying to devise a model yeah
we diksha do that exactly we tried to do
that in fact I'm proud to say I was one
of the first people with this group of
buying a commercial 3d printer to print
such circuits to do it okay they were a
little failure though mostly because the
3d printers weren't very good then and
you know my interest then went off
elsewhere but people have various people
have approached me and about trying to
do making fractal manufacturing
processes and I suspect that sometime in
the future someone will do that and now
to answer your question about computers
computers are a place where it could be
fantastic today that quantum computers
well it could be even in quantities but
even regular computers because they're
quite regular computers do have a very
crude fractal structure but no one as
far as I know the designers of chips of
computers putting chips together use at
all the advantages of a fractal geometry
and just to repeat to everybody what
what Stewart alluded to in the
the the way our body works is that you
know we need to deliver to all these
cells and the efficient way of doing it
is to have this hierarchical branching
network system would take something
macroscopic delivers it to something
microscopic and the optimal way of doing
it is for that system to be fractal
meaning that you know you look at any
piece of it it looks like any other
piece you know like a river it's so it's
social all the way down from the top to
the bottom roughly speaking and that it
turns out and in traditional fractal
geometry that adds sort of speak an
added dimensionality to the problem and
the number four comes about because
these networks have to service cells
that live in a three-dimensional space
so they have this kind of three
dimensionality automatically to them and
the fractal thing adds a one to them and
so the four is actually three plus one I
mean that doesn't greet hi and realize
that doesn't actually explain anything
but that's the way it works out and by
the way you can of course test that try
to test it by looking at two-dimensional
plants which we did we did actually we
grew where the student grow a bunch of
two-dimensional plants you know things
that just go along a surface and test
the theory to see instead of the number
four three plus one it should be the
number two two dimensions plus one
should be three and the trouble is you
couldn't grow and plants big enough to
really test it sufficiently but let's
put it this way the paper we published
said the data were consistent with the
with the third rather the quarter
yes I can see that this conversation is
capable of becoming fractal and
and I want to thank you for coming again
to there and I thought you might be
[Applause]
[Music]